what are aaron's best moments in attack
on titan well let's find out number 10
aaron's first fight against the female
titan
this fight is iconic in many ways it is
the first time we see two titans clash
against each other this fight starts
when the female titan escapes the survey
corpse trap and murders entire levi's
squad aaron watches his friends die
knowing that he could have prevented it
he questions himself and his resolve
before madness overtakes him and he
transforms to unwieldly battle the
female titan even though he initially
had the upper hand against the crippled
female titan aaron quickly expends all
of his energy because he was only led by
anger and if we learned anything
throughout this show it's that anger
doesn't always help the female titan
gets up and knocks attacks titan's head
off and ends up eating aaron even though
aaron's first fight against the female
titan ends in a swift defeat his
emotions and determination to avenge his
fallen friends got all of us heated up
number nine aaron plugs the hole in wall
road
imagine your life is depending on the
outcome of one mission well that's
exactly what occurs here when the
military is trying to decide whether
aaron should be executed or not assigned
with the task to lift a giant boulder to
plug the hole in wall rose and prevent
more titans from entering the district
everything goes wrong when aaron all of
a sudden attacks mikasa before knocking
himself unconscious when his body fails
to regenerate the mission is declared a
failure armin arrives on the scene and
convinces mikasa to go help fiend off
the titans while he tries to get through
to aaron armin manages to rouse aaron
slightly by stabbing into his titan's
nape and piercing his human body he
manages to bring aaron back by reminding
him of their desire to see the world
together causing aaron to remember how
he wanted to join the survey corpse and
destroy all the titans with the survey
corpse hopes and aaron seemingly
dismayed aaron recovers to plug the hole
while the survey corpse members rally
and give their lives to protect him in
the process this scene represents not
only aaron's fight against the titans
but also his immense value to humanity
number eight aaron defeating the
colossal titan
the colossal titan is the trademark for
the show ever since his first appearance
in season one fans always go crazy when
the god of destruction appears during
the battle for shiganshina zeke throws
bertolt over the wall and he transforms
into his titan form while aaron uses his
titan to shield his comrades from this
blast he attempts to draw colossal
titan's attention away but bertolt
ignores him and aaron and his comrades
are left with no choice but to engage
him aaron grabs one of bertolt's legs
and attempts to push him back but
bertolt simply kicks aaron to the side
of walmaria leaving him incapacitated
that's some serious football skills
there bertolt after armin wakes him up
aaron reluctantly goes along with
armin's plan pretending to fall down to
the ground and become immobile while
armin pretends to act shocked escaping
his titan form after hardening it aaron
then grapples onto the nape of the
colossus titan slices it open and yanks
bertolt out i don't know about you guys
but seeing aaron defeat colossal titan
was mind blowing to me
number 7 aaron saves mikasa
in season 1 we got to see a flashback of
mikasa's childhood and how she met aaron
well let's just say it's not how usually
kids meet for their first time when he
was a young boy he went on a trip with
his father to meet the ackermanns
however when they arrived at mikasa's
house they found out that her parents
were murdered and mikasa was missing
enraged with the scene aaron tracked the
robbers who killed mikasa's parents to a
small cabin in the forest aaron acted
scared and claimed that he was lost when
the man approached aaron he took out a
hidden knife and killed him instantly
when the second man came after him with
an axe aaron stabbed him as well not
knowing that there was a third killer
aaron let his guard down and was
attacked he told mikasa that she had to
fight and she killed the last man that
was responsible for her parents deaths
this scene showed us not only what aaron
is capable of doing when led by anger
but also what made mikasa the person she
is today number 6 aaron's hardening
ability
[Music]
the middle of battle at reese chapel rod
reese drinks the titan serum and starts
transforming into pure titan aaron
depressed after learning that his father
killed the entire rhys family begs
historia to allow her father to eat him
historia refuses telling him she is
still his friend levi and his squad
arrive in time to save his story from
the blast made from rods titan and get
the keys to aaron's chains the ceiling
begins to collapse due to the massive
size of rod's titan and the squad's
escape is blocked this is the moment
where aaron realizes that everyone with
him is going to die he starts
apologizing for being useless and levi
gives him the choice of deciding who
lives and who dies needless to say aaron
chooses humanity he starts running and
grabs a bottle labeled armor that had
fallen out of rod satchel and bites into
it after transforming into a titan aaron
is able to harden his titan and
reinforce the firmness of the cavern
around it and save everyone proving yet
again that when it comes to hard choices
aaron will always step up and save his
comrades
number 5 aaron invades marley
once aaron learned the truth of the
outside world he snuck into marley and
waited for his moment to strike he
tricked falco into sending multiple
letters to the survey corpse telling him
that they are for his family once they
joined him he launched a surprise attack
on marley his main opponent was the
warhammer titan who aaron manages to
attack before it can fully transform it
appears he has the upper hand until a
hardened pillar pierces through him the
warhammer titan finishes its
transformation and constructs a hammer
to fight aaron as the battle continues
aaron strategically uses each of his
titan transformations to assess the
warhammer strength until he discovers
that the user of the titan is located
underground transforming back into the
attack titan he sees a hole in the
street from where a long cable of flesh
comes out attached to the warhammer
titan aaron reaches in and grabs the
crystallized body of laura tiber
severing her connection and disabling
the warhammer when he bites the crystal
he breaks his titan's jaw on the
hardened surface well aaron being the
smart man he is he realized that he can
use the jaw titan to break the crystal
and eat the warhammer and he did in the
most epic way possible
number four aaron's second fight against
the female titan
[Applause]
every major fight in the anime always
deserves a rematch an attack on titan
just had to give us a round two of aaron
against the female titan when annie is
revealed as the female titan aaron
immediately becomes delusional he
struggles to believe that the female
titan who murdered his friends is the
same comrade who trained with him for
years while she continues to kill more
scouts aaron tries to transform into his
titan form but cannot due to the shock
and disbelief at annie's betrayal he is
reminded of the lives annie took as the
female titan as well as his vow to
exterminate the titans allowing him to
finally overcome his doubts and
transform into the attack titan the two
titans start battling each other and
crushing anything that comes in their
way even though aaron is in better
control of his titan this time around he
is ultimately no match for annie's
superior fighting technique and
hardening abilities and he gets beaten
up again but in the end with a little
help from mikasa he manages to pin down
the female titan as corpse soldiers pry
open her nape
number three aaron uses power of the
founding titan for the first time
aaron never forgot the face of the titan
that killed his mother so we were
shocked as much as he was when we saw
smiling titan appear in front of him at
the end of season two while hans
distracts the titan aaron shouts from
acosta to free him believing that he is
the only one who can save their lives
but when he tries to transform into a
titan nothing happens because he is
still recovering from his injuries
devastated when hans gets eaten and
devastated at the thought that nothing
has changed from when he was a kid he
curses himself for being too weak and
unable to do anything
mikasa tries to reassure him thanking
him for everything that he's done for
her aaron gets up and in a desperate
attempt punches the smiling titan in the
hand as it reaches for him aaron screams
and accidentally activates the power of
the founding titan for the first time
everywhere around them the titans that
were fighting the soldiers turned their
attention to the smiling titan
surrounding and devouring it emotions in
the scene were just too much to bear
number two aaron's first fight against
reiner
reveal is amongst the most epic moments
of the entire series for a second time
aaron is betrayed by his friends at the
beginning he was in disbelief but reiner
removes the bandage off of his arm and
reveals that his wounds are regenerating
the shock in aaron's eyes left us all
speechless after mikasa's failed attempt
to kill the traitors they both transform
into their titan forms and attack
thinking back on his memories with
reiner and bertolt and the dream they
all shared about returning to their
homes and enraged aaron transforms and
gives us one of the best titan battles
ever even during the fight aaron can't
help but think about his admiration for
reiner realizing he cannot defeat the
armored titan he uses a different
strategy and attempts to subdue reiner
with the submission hold aaron begins
applying pressure to his nape causing
its armor to crack however before he can
break reiner out of his titan reiner
begins roaring causing berthold's titan
to roll off the top of the wall landing
atop both of them wow talking about an
intense scene
number one declaration of war
imagine walking into a room and seeing a
ghost well that's exactly how reiner
felt when he was led to a basement by
falco where aaron was waiting for him
upon reiner's arrival he asks aaron why
he's in marley and aaron responds that
he is there for the same reason as
reiner he has no choice revealing that
he has already slit his hand in
preparation to transform if need be
aaron insists that reiner sit with him
to listen to the play overhearing willy
claim that aaron is a rebel against
peace and that he admits that he is
indeed the bad guy but argues that
warriors were also the bad guys when
they invaded walmaria he admits that he
understands the suffering reiner went
through causing the latter to break down
and ask that aaron kill him what is
amazing in this scene is that we got to
see a whole new aaron the one who comes
to see more lands as humans and even as
good people it is the peak of aaron's
self-hatred as he has now become the
same as the people he swore to
exterminate as he helped reiner to his
feet aaron says that he now understands
that they are the same and declares that
he will continue until he wipes out his
enemies transforming into the attack
titan aaron breaks out of the building
and in the most legendary way kills
willie tiber declaring the war to the
entire world
is he still the good guy or did he turn
evil it's up to you to decide and we
will see you guys in the next video bye